one question that we get a lot at YC is
how to find a technical co-founder this
is how I would think through this
problem first I would start with your
friends um how many of your friends do
you really enjoy talking to and who know
how to write code and even better write
code every day is a primary part of
their job I advise that you actually
make a list of all of these people rank
the top five and then make those people
real offers a lot of what happens is
that people have friends they might want
to start companies with but they feel
uncomfortable asking they think oh well
my friend works at Google or he makes
this big salary or she's up for a
promotion I don't think they're ever
going to want to do if you don't ask
you'll never know and your friend might
be at a job waiting to leave but no
one's asking them or let's be more more
clear they're friend isn't asking them
to come and let's and let's start
something the part of asking someone to
start a company though is to make them
an offer like how much salary can you
pay them if anything how much Equity are
you willing to give them so you don't
want to make have an informal
conversation you actually want to make
them a real offer hey um Samantha I'd
like you to be my co-founder I'd like to
give you 40% of the company we've only
raised a small amount of money so I
can't afford to pay you much but as soon
as we you raise more I'm happy to pay
you this salary that's what it takes a
real offer not like hey can you help me
with my project on the weekends or hey
would you be interested or hey would you
just code this on the side for me
everyone's asking Engineers to do that
type of work and it's often the not very
good way to recruit a technical
co-founder okay after we work through
friends let's say that no there no one
on the list that um says yes or you
can't build a list you friends who know
how to write code the next group of
people to think about is co-workers go
through the same exact process with the
people that you work with at work people
you like people you get along with
figure out who they are make a list rank
it make real
offers now let's say no one at work and
know one your friends the next thing you
have to think about is how do I build a
network with software engineers in it
the often best way to do this is to go
get another job to go work at a
technology company where software
Engineers work now a lot of times people
get on this route they think oh I need
to work at a big company like Google or
Facebook unfortunately if you're not
technical a lot of the time when you
work at these big companies you are kept
far away from engineering and so it's a
lot harder to become friends with
Engineers so counterintuitively or maybe
intuitively depending how you think
about it the best way to build an
engineering network and to become
friends with more Engineers is to work
at a technology startup you know to work
at a small company that's 50 people or
less where everyone's sitting together
talking together having lunch together
and interacting with each other and
doing work together by making friends
with those co-workers by making friends
with their friends you'll start building
your network and you can start figuring
out who you might consider working with
now sometimes that does take longer you
know it might take a year or two working
at that company before you have the
network and you find the people you want
to work with but remember doing a
startup can be a whole life's work so if
it takes a couple years to get started
in the scheme of things if this is
something you're doing for 10 plus years
that's probably worth it one more thing
that you can consider is learning how to
code there are a lot more res resources
online right now that can help you learn
how to code everything from code academy
to Lambda school and a whole bunch of
other products so you can always go that
direction if you're inclined one last
note before I close if you're a college
student one thing you should understand
is that one of the best places to find
future co-founders is in college by all
means if you ever think that you might
want to create a startup one day and you
don't know how to
code one thing I would advise you to do
is make friends with people who are
learning how to code in school um
they might turn out to be your future
co-founder 125 5 10 years from now um I
was extremely lucky I was friends with
Justin Con in college um he was working
he was learning how to code and working
in a startup and he was friends with
another guy named emit cheer who was a
great software engineer and when they
decided to do a company called Justin TV
I was friends with them they recruited
me and Bam I had two amazing co-founders
directly from school um college is a
massively massively used opportunity to
find co-founders and you shouldn't uh
forget that thank you very much